اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من رفاح اهلا
بكم قصف جوي ومدفعي متواصل على مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان في مناطق عده من القطاع
ووزاره الصحه في غزه تعلن ان قصف الاحتلال
ادى الى اكثر من
163 شهيدا خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
وانتشال جثامين عشرات الشهداء بعد قصف
منزل في حي الدرج في مدينه غزه ومن محيط
مستشفى ناصر بخانيونس جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابطين واصابه 35 من
افراده في معارك غزه خلال الساعات ال 24
الماضيه واجراء عمليه انزال جوي للامدادات
العسكريه للفرقه 98 في خانيونس وكتائب
القسام تقول انها اشتبكت مع قوه تابعه
للاحتلال جنوب خانيونس واوقعت افرادها بين
قتيل وجريح واستهدفت ناقله جند في جباليه
الخارجيه القطريه تعلن نجاح وسطه قطريه في
التوصل لاتفاق بين اسرائيل وحماس بادخال
مساعدات للمدنيين في غزه مقابل ايصال
ادويه للمحتجزين في القطاع مكتب نتنياهو
يؤكد ان ايصال الادويه للمختطفين سيبدا
اليوم الاربعاء والبيت الابيض يقول ان
مستشار الامن القومي ناقش مع رئيس الوزراء
القطري جهود اطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن
المتبقين لدى ح
استشهاد تسعه شبان فلسطينيين في عمليتي
قصف بمسيرتي تابعتين للاحتلال استهدفتا
سيارتين في مخيم بلاطه شرق نابلس ومخيم
طولكرم وجيش الاحتلال يحتجز جثامين عدد من
الشهداء ويقتحم مدينه الظاهريه جنوب
الخليل وسط مواجهات مع شبان
فلسطينيين الى
اللقاء l